how do I answer this when there's
puppies running
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you talking about Santa comes
every year even the dogs are at odds
about this okay I can tell them they
just do what they want everything about
the holidays is just so much fun but I
don't even know how to explain it while
I'm watching these puppies fight with
each other they're so adorable I can't
believe they're here I'll be happy with
anything it's a thought the County come
on look they're Cheon betrayed so this
is a natural
[Music]
all I love for Christmas is my the first
Christmas song that I ever wrote for my
first Christmas album which is called
Merry Christmas and there's a new
animated movie about a little girl that
wants a puppy for Christmas I'm just
here with posing and playing with
puppies and talking about other things
but to answer your question but wait
[Music]
soon as I get back in the studio after
Christmas because right now we're
celebrating the fact that we have a I
[Music]
wasn't thinking about that I was
recording a Christmas song - that's a
boring answer but is this food look at
this please tell me you're getting this
adorable BuzzFeed
[Music]